20 juillet 2019
à trois jours de fusées de la terre
cinquante ans après leurs premiers pas
sur la lune
les hommes sont désormais des dizaines à
habiter ici en permanence une véritable
colonie internationale qui vit de façon
pratiquement autonome produisant dans
d'immenses r la base de son alimentation
et dans de véritables usines l'oxygène
de la vie
pour ces sélénites comme on les appelle
le travail ne manque pas il y a les
scientifiques des géologues des
chimistes ou des astronomes qui ont
installé sur la face cachée d'immenses
télescope pointé sur l'espace lointain
il y a aussi les techniciens qui outre
les travaux d'entretien de la base
assure le ravitaillement en carburant
des véhicules au long cours en transit
vers d'autres planètes
quant au produit estampillé mellow mood
c'est-à-dire fait sur la lune on annonce
pour bientôt leur commercialisation sur
terre
atteindre la lune on en rêvait depuis la
nuit des temps
un des projets les plus fous c'est ce
canon géant tirant des normes au but
chargé de candidats au voyage
intersidéral
c'est ce qu'avait imaginé le visionnaire
français jules verne en 1865 dans son
roman de la terre à la lune un projet
repris six cent trente ans plus tard par
les créatifs de disneyland paris est
appelée space mountain
frissons garantis même si on y attend
pas la lune cette fiction on la retrouve
au début du siècle avec le cinéaste
georges méliès dans son film le voyage
dans la lune puis au début des années 50
la bande dessinée s'empare à son tour de
l'imaginaire avec hergé et son fidèle
tintin dans objectif lune et on a marché
sur la lune dernière fiction 15 ans
seulement avant le premier pas bien
réelle de neil amstrong
si l'homme est ainsi parvenu il ya 30
ans a foulé le sol de la lune il n'a
toujours pas réussi aujourd'hui encore à
percer les mystères de sa naissance et
les hypothèses ne manquent pas la lune
existent et elles ailleurs dans le
système solaire est un terreau été
capturé par la gravitation terrestre
et elle à résidus de la terre n'est de
l'émission spontanée de haute énergie
qui aurait provoqué une projection de
matières sur l'orbité terrestre à l'
autre hypothèse l'ensemble terre lune at
il été formée d'un seul tenant à partir
de matière solaire
enfin la lune serait elle tout
simplement un morceau de terre arraché
lors de sa collision avec un corps
céleste de grande dimension là encore
mystère
malgré la course effrénée à la lune qui
on va le voir va durer près de vingt ans
entre soviétiques et américains vient
des tâches dhombres demeure aujourd'hui
encore sur les origines de sa création
les soviétiques vont prendre de vitesse
les américains et atteindront les
premiers la lune en 1959 avec leurs
sondes l'une à 2 sept ans plus tard ce
sera le premier alunissage en douceur
ce sont eux encore qui rapporteront /
tél les 100 premiers grammes
d'échantillons lunaires et qui
réaliseront la première photo de la face
cachée en 17 ans à 22 sonde soviétique
se poseront à six sur la lune et de
véritables robots l'élu la robe et deux
parcours ont une cinquantaine de
kilomètres transmettant près de cent
mille photos
mais après quatre échecs successifs de
leur fusée géante n 1
les soviétiques devront renoncer la mort
dans l'âme a marché sur la lune
laissant ainsi la voie libre à
l'amérique du président kennedy qui
avait décidé d'entrer solennellement
dans la course le 12 septembre 1962 par
ce discours historique
pourquoi la lune
pourquoi la choisir comme but se
demande-t-on pourquoi en gravit les plus
hautes montagnes
pourquoi il y à 35 ans on a traversé
l'atlantique à l'université de rice
texas
nous avons choisi d'aller sur la lune
dans les dix ans à venir et de faire
beaucoup d'autres grand chose non pas
parce qu'elles sont faciles à réaliser
mais parce que la tâche est ardue
avant de tenter une première expédition
sur la lune les américains apprendront à
mieux la connaître en la photographiant
sous tous les angles
ce seront les programmes rangers luna
orbiteur et surveille or 25 sont dans 10
ans et plus de cent mille clichés
destinés à choisir avec précision les
lieux des futurs sites d'alunissage des
missions qui détermineront aussi la
nature physique du sol permettant ainsi
de définir les caractéristiques des
véhicules destinés à s'y poser
principale difficulté pour les futurs
équipages les manoeuvres d'alunissage
simulé sur ce drôle d'engin baptisé le
lit cage volant on s'entraîne ici à
effectuer les 150 derniers mètres avant
le contact avec le sol lunaire en tenant
compte de la pesanteur qui est six fois
moins importante que sur la terre et
pour les futures explorations de la lune
on s'entraîne à conduire la jeep open à
véhicules électriques tout terrain
révolutionnaire au milieu des années 60
le programme apollo est prêt
pour atteindre la lune la nasa a conçu
une cabine capable de transporter trois
astronautes entre la terre et la lune
une fusée porteuse d'une saturn 5 à 3
étages de 100 mètres de haut et un
véhicule transports composée d'un module
de commande et d'un module lunaire le
lem
après avoir parcouru 60 mille kilomètres
le vaisseau spatial et maintenant
attirer par l'attraction lunaire à 100
kilomètres de la lune on à l'unité
rétrofusées afin de ralentir sa course à
deux des trois astronautes prennent
place dans le même qui se séparent alors
du module de commande
après l'allumage de ces rétrofusées la
vitesse du lem diminue jusqu'au contact
avec le sol
or vêtus de leur combinaison spatiale
pressurisé les astronautes sont
désormais prêts à travailler
la mission terminée il regagne le lem et
c'est le décollage puis le rendez-vous
avec le module de commande rester en
orbite de la lune
après transfert de l'équipage le lem
devenus inutiles et largué puis c'est
l'allumage des moteurs 1 100 km
d'altitude
la capsule protégé par son bouclier
thermique traverse un véritable mur de
flammes puis c'est l'ouverture des
parachutes de freinage l'amerrissage et
la récupération de l'équipage il restait
à la nasa a passé de la théorie et des
dessins à la réalité
neil amstrong
buzz aldrin
ces trois hommes ou plutôt deux d'entre
eux partent ce matin pour la lune
le troisième michael collins devra se
contenter de contempler dans le paysage
nous sommes le 16 juillet 1969 il est un
peu plus de 7 heures du matin à cap
canaveral en floride dans le centre de
contrôle on a bien sûr une pensée ce
matin pour grissom mois était chez fille
il y a deux ans tout près de là ont péri
brûlées vifs dans l'incendié de leur
capsule apollo 1
mais on a aussi présent à l'esprit les
différents vols préparatoire à l'épopée
lunaire qui se sont parfaitement
déroulées un grand joue également pour
werner von braun le père du programme
les nerfs américains qui sont ici très
confiants à quelques secondes seulement
du lancement
côté public c'est de la folie
invités journalistes et curieux ont
investi depuis plusieurs jours les lieux
de peur de rater l'événement
l'amérique et le reste du monde
rudin leurs sons fleurs
dès la mise à feu des moteurs de la
saturn le bruit est assourdissant
la poussée exercée par la fusée est
impressionnante elle
pour la première fois des hommes
viennent de quitter la terre pour aller
marcher sur le sol du seul satellite
naturel de la terre
un globe terrestre majestueux qu'on peut
pour la première fois admirée dans sa
totalité
le nom de cet américain neil armstrong
va bientôt être connus de la planète
entière tout comme celui de son collègue
soviétique youri gagarine qui lui il y a
huit ans avait été le premier à
effectuer à premier bond dans l'espace
le monde méduses on peut suivre en
direct à la télévision
le voyage sur fond de sol lunaire de
seul m cette grosse araignée baptisé
eagle l'aigle qui vient de se séparer du
module de commande et qui plonge
maintenant vers la lune au centre de
contrôle de houston
les techniciens ont les yeux rivés sur
les écrans
oh
100 pieds 30 mètres d'altitude le site
d'alunissage visé est la mère de la
contrainte est situé à proximité
immédiate de l'équateur lunaire mais
l'endroit semble rocailleux et dangereux
soixante secondes avec cette manoeuvre
de dernière minute les réservoirs du lem
sont pratiquement à sec moteur coupé
houston l'aigle s'est posé
il était temps car à 30 secondes près
c'était la catastrophe
armstrong dira alors très ému en posant
son pied gauche sur la lune
un petit pas pour l'homme mais à pas de
géant pour l'humanité
après un voyage de 8 jours dont moins de
24 heures passées sur la lune les trois
hommes seront partout fêtés en héros
comme ici à new york
tous les trois quitteront la nasa un an
après le retour sur terre et aucun
d'entre eux ne repartira plus ensuite
dans l'espace leurs exploits seront
racontées dans des centaines de livres
de vidéocassettes de cd rom et plus
récemment sur des sites internet de
trente ans après la conquête de la lune
continue aujourd'hui encore à faire
rêver et à illustrer des centaines de
timbres poste de tous les pays de la
planète
pendant les quatre ans que durera le
programme apollo
cet équipage de trois astronautes
prendront ainsi tour à tour le chemin de
la lune
un cérémonial immuable me minutieusement
en place dans la nasa afin d'éviter que
le moindre grain de sable ne vienne
enrayer la belle mécanique dans
l'ascenseur qui franchit les 100
premiers mètres du fabuleux périple une
distance totale en ligne droite de 380
4400 km c'est la dernière chance de
jeter un coup d'oeil rapide là bas à
cette planète qu'ils vont quitter
pendant une douzaine de jours
je
mais le feu la fumée et le tonnerre les
cinq moteur du premier étage de la
saturn 5 vomissent maintenant des
montagnes de flammes
la fusée qui tentent de s'échapper de sa
tour de lancement brûlent chaque seconde
15 tonnes de kérosène et d'oxygène
liquide engloutissant sans compter les
trois millions et demi de litres de
carburant de ses réservoirs
la poussée dépasse maintenant les 3000
tonnes la lumière dégagée par les
tuyères est aveuglante
la vitesse de la fusée qui se libèrent
rapidement de son carburant augmente de
façon vertigineuse jusqu'à atteindre
tout à l'heure les quarante mille
kilomètres heures nécessaires pour
s'affranchir de la gravitation terrestre
après deux minutes trente de vol c'est
la séparation du premier étage
neuf minutes après avoir quitté cap
canaveral est à près de 200 km
d'altitude
le deuxième étage de la fusée se
séparent à son tour puis ce sera la mise
à feu du 3ème étage
apollo pourra alors quitter la banlieue
de notre planète pour prendre la
direction de la lune le train spatial va
alors tourner sur lui-même afin
d'exposer de façon uniforme sa carapace
aux variations de température entre
ombre et soleil passant de plus 170 ha -
170° premières manoeuvres séparer le lem
du reste du véhicule spatial qui après
s'être retourné sur lui même viendra de
nouveau siar nerfs à l'intérieur de la
cabine la température est maintenue
entre 21 et 24 degrés alors que dehors
la lune approche c'est l'heure pour les
deux élus de rejoindre leur chaloupe de
débarquement
en orbite autour de la lune c'est la
séparation entre le lem et le module de
commande qui servira de relais avec la
terre désormais seul pour une période de
trois à cinq jours
l'astronaute privée de l'une emploiera
son temps à la photographier et a
effectué toute une série d'expériences
scientifiques en apesanteur
quant aux l'aiment d'abord la tête en
bas à quelques kilomètres d'altitude
il se redresse présentant alors c'est
énorme pied vers le sol près à
l'alunissage les commentaires par
l'équipage des 90 dernières secondes
avant l'arrivée sur la gauche
mon dieu je ne peux pas le croire c'est
incroyable c'est fantastique ici houston
vous êtes autorisés à l'atterrissage
en douze ans par pressions successives
la mise à feu des moteurs le lem a
maintenant pratiquement atteint sa
vitesse d'un message qui doit être de 9
km heure
600 kits ou 100 m
200 pieds 60 m l'alunissage est
désormais obligatoire
tron freiner la descente et c'est
risquer de manquer de carburant pour
amortir l'impact final pas assez freiné
c'est alors la collision violente avec
le sol voire la destruction du lem et la
condamnation de l'équipage à une mort
certaine mais heureusement on n'en est
pas là 60 pieds 20 mètres il faut se
poser aux actes
les douze américains qui ont marché sur
la lune iront passer une durée totale de
19 jours et 11 heures dont un peu plus
de 80 heures à l'extérieur du lem
démarche lunéa facilitée par la faible
gravité c'est dire qu'un homme de 60 kg
n'en pèse que 10 sur la lune
des dépassements gênées par l'épaisse
combinaisons spatiales que doivent
revêtir les astronautes avant de quitter
leur vaisseau l'environnement de la lune
est en effet très hostile pour l'homme
absent terre rayonnement cosmique non
filtrés température pouvant varier entre
+ 100 degrés au soleil est inférieur à
moins de 100 degrés à l'ombre
la transformer parfois en véritable
déménageurs ils transporteront et
installeront nombre d'appareils
scientifique suivis pas à pas par les
géologues il laboure on le sol
recueillant des échantillons de toutes
tailles représentant un poids de près de
400 kilos de roches lunaires une
exploration lunaire qui aura coûté
quelque 150 milliards de francs sur 10
ans au contribuable américain des jeux
d'enfants qui amuseront bien sûr les
astronautes et les contrôleurs de la
nasa mais qui feront grincer les dents à
beaucoup d'autres
à l'heure où l'amérique s'enlise dans la
guerre du vietnam sur la lune
on jouera au golf mais on chantera même
abordé jeep lunaire
dans le module de commande l'astronaute
rester seul suit pas à pas le bon
déroulement de la mission
il procède par ailleurs à toute une
série d'observations et même à la
cartographie de ce monde si proche et
pourtant inaccessible
l'egypte étaient de véritables bijoux de
technologie des véhicules 30 j'ai
construit en aluminium est équipé de
gare de bus pour éviter que la poussière
lunaire n'aveugle le conducteur d'une
voiture électrique
roulant à la vitesse de 8 km heure est
capable de gravir des pentes de 20% ces
rover en liaison télévision direct avec
la terre auront permis à six astronautes
de parcourir pro b 100 km sur le sol
lunaire base lunaire pour houston
vous êtes autorisé au décollage si je
comprends bien nous sommes les numéros 1
sur la piste d'envol dialogue et
hollandais sang froid alors qu'a lieu
une des opérations les plus délicates de
la mission le décollage du lem pour ce
faire on utilise sa partie basse
comptable de lancement qui est
abandonnée sur la une
la partie haute dans laquelle ont pris
place les deux astronautes servant le
véhicule de retour le 14 décembre 1972
pour la sixième et dernière fois les
hommes qui tombent de la sorte le sol
lunaire une véritable poursuite sur fond
de lune
s'engage alors avec le module de
commande rester en orbite le lem ce
drôle d'engin en aluminium aux formes
apparemment blizzard avait été conçu de
façon purement fonctionnel et sans
soucis d'aérodynamisme en raison de
l'absence de tout densité dans
l'environnement lui même
on envisage aujourd'hui de retourner sur
la lune mais avec des robots des robots
télécommandés qui permettraient sans
quitter son fauteuil de revivre l'épopée
lunaire
on a lui dirai dans la mer de la
tranquillité tout près d'apollo 11
on irait voir tous les engins abandonné
comme les sondes russe et américaine
les différents l'est mais les trois
rover avant de parcourir les 500
kilomètres qui séparent l'équateur de la
lune du dernier site d'alunissage
d'apollo 17
tout un programme
une fois l'arrimage effectués c'est le
transfert dans le module de commande et
de services le passage des deux hommes
mais aussi de tout leur matériel
de retour de la lune et notamment des
précieux échantillons de roches
soigneusement édité le lem est alors
abandonné dans l'espace
l'heure pour les astronautes d'une
dernière petite toilette avant le retour
sur terre puis c'est l'allumage des
moteurs et la descente vers la terre à
120 km d'altitude
la capsule se sépare de son compartiment
des machines et à plus de 10 km par
seconde protégé par son bouclier
thermique elle plonge alors dans les
couches denses de l'atmosphère en
trouver le plasma dont la température
dépasse les 2000 devrait apollo ici le
panta vion us hornet
on est prêt pour la récupération à 8 km
de la surface de l'océan pacifique
un premier parachute ralenti violemment
la capsule qui sans cela exploserait en
s'écrasant lors de son contact avec la
mer à trois kilomètres d'altitude
trois petits puis trois gros parachute
termine d'amortir la descente
vertigineuse de la capsule vers l'océan
c'est alors l'amerrissage en douceur
suivi de la récupération en canot de
sauvetage puis en panier à salade et
enfin en hélicoptère des trois hommes
direction le porte avions
arrivé sur le porte-avions les premiers
astronautes de retour de la lune n'en
était pas pour autant au bout de leurs
peines la nasa craignant des risques de
contamination avait en effet décidé de
soumettre les hommes à une véritable
quarantaine à l'abri du monde extérieur
ce fut le cas pour les astronautes
d'apollo 11 accueilli sur lieu à 100m
par le président américain richard nixon
merbah zemma et bien je veux que vous
sachiez que je suis l'homme le plus
heureux du monde
et je ne dis pas ça parce que j'ai
l'honneur d'être le président des états
unis mais parce que j'ai le privilège de
me parler au nom de tant de personnes
pour vous souhaiter la bienvenue pour
votre retour sur terre
grâce à ce que vous avez fait le monde
ne sera jamais plus comme avant et je
veux vous remercier pour cela
houston nous avons un problème ici
houston vous pouvez répéter houston nous
avons un problème
ok apollo 13 attendez on s'en occupe
à trois jours de voyage et 320 m le
réservoir d'oxygène du module services
d'après au xiii vient d'exposer
détruisant le moteur et différents
éléments vitaux du module de commande
l'opinion publique pourtant déjà blasé
par l'aventuré lunaire se passionne
aussi tôt alors sur le sort de ces trois
hommes en perdition entre terre et lune
abc news apollo 13 à des problèmes
sérieux qui pourrait annuler la mission
lunaire
les trois hommes voient maintenant leur
terme et on s'échappe et dans l'espace
la décision est alors aussitôt prise
d'annuler la mission lunaire
à bord l'équipage parvient à garder le
moral et à s'alimenter normalement le
lem va être utilisé comme canot de
sauvetage
arrimé au module de commande qui
lui-même servira pour le retour sur
terre pour conserver le peu d'énergie
restante
l'équipage va vivre dans l'obscurité et
le froid glacial du vide spatial
alors qu à houston une procédure
d'urgence décidée
il faut utiliser le moteur du lem pour
passer derrière la mine et revenez sur
terre mais l'équipage fatigué et anxieux
fait des erreurs de calcul la situation
à bord devient catastrophique à court de
carburant et l'oxygène
les trois astronautes d'apollo 13 un
chapon de justesse à la mort et
parviendront à revenir sains et saufs
sur terre
six jours après l'avoir quittée c'est
leur épopée que fait revivre dans ce
film catastrophe à grand spectacle
apollo 13 le cinéaste américain ron
howard
un centre de contrôle de houston nous
sommes prêt pour le décollage
et
ouvrir les vannes à oxygène
ok
nous avons un problème c'est un problème
d'instruments de mesure où un véritable
problème
j'ai branché ce cas on m'avait demandé
retour à la réalité avec les trois héros
véritable de cette périlleuse mission
qui aura montré que l'espace reste un
lieu dangereux et inhospitalier pour
l'homme
une belle histoire qui se termine bien
et qui relancera l'intérêt du public
pour l'aventuré lunaire au cours des six
exploration lunaire on ramassera et en
rapportera sur terre 2000 pierre de lune
représentant un poids de 380 kg
des échantillons qui seront transportés
et manipuler avec beaucoup de soin
d'abord de peur qu'ils contiennent une
quelconque substance nocive pour l'homme
mais aussi et surtout afin que les
scientifiques est à leur disposition des
spécimens de roches lunaires les plus
proches de leur condition d'origine
les principaux enseignements de ces
analyses ont d'abord porté sur l'aspect
physique de la lune
elle possède une croûte de 60 kilomètres
d'épaisseur un manteau jusqu'à 1000 km
de profondeur et une couche visqueuse
partiellement liquide qui atteint 1800
km ces premières analyses sont
rassurantes
elle montre que le sol lunaire ne
contient aucun élément dangereux pour
l'homme au point de vue géologique la
lune est composé de roches dont les plus
anciennes datent de plus de quatre
milliards et demi d'années soit elles se
sont mélangées entre elles soit elles
sont d'origine volcanique
soit elles se sont transformées par
l'impact des météorites 1 enfin en ce
qui concerne la biologie on a pu
conclure de façon certaine à l'absence
de vie passée ou présente sur la lune ni
sous formes d'organismes vivant ni sous
forme de faux cils et il n'existe sur la
lune ni eau ni oxygène une vie végétale
comme animal inexistante sur la lune ne
veut pas dire une vie impossible pour
demain de vastes sert à alimenter en eau
et en oxygène à l'abri de la rigueur et
d agressions du milieu extérieur
pourrait permettre d'assurer
l'autosuffisance alimentaire de ces
aventuriers colons du troisième
millénaire
plus de quarante ans après avoir examiné
pour la première fois ces échantillons
venus d'un autre monde
des scientifiques de la planète terre
continue aujourd'hui encore de les
étudier et de les analyser
cette troisième génération de chercheurs
espèrent qu'en utilisant de nouvelles
technologies a connu alors elle
parviendra à percer enfin les derniers
secrets de la lune
tel le mystère de sa naissance qu'elle
conserve encore toujours jalousement
cachés